hello there how do vision transformers
work this is what i have been asking
myself lately too we are already tired
of hearing news about vision
transformers beating state of the art
here and there and everywhere everywhere
in computer vision means imagenet
but we have also come to see vision
transformers with convolutional biases
in them like the hierarchical swin
transformer which has a limited
attention window and we started to get
some mixed feelings about what works
best is it now convolutions or is it
multi-head self-attention
in the last video we got entirely
confused about who wins the fight
between convents and transformers we saw
with convnext how a modernized convnet
can compete with transformers so it's
time to read and explain this paper that
brings more insight into what makes
vision transformers so
special attention and why they are maybe
not as special as we think or not for
the reasons we originally had in mind oh
here is my alert that we should thank
weights and biases for supporting us for
this video today we want to highlight
the weights and biases alert feature you
can be notified via slack or email if
your weights and biases run has crashed
or whether a custom trigger has been
reached such as your loss going to nan
or a step in your machine learning
pipeline has completed weights and
biases alerts apply to all projects
where your launch runs including both
personal and team projects get started
with weights and biases alerts in two
quick ways turn on alerts in your
weights and biases user settings you can
get notified by a slack and or email for
whether your run is finished whether it
has crashed or any other custom trigger
you like for custom triggers add 1db dot
alert to your code wherever you'd like
to be alerted for a custom trigger i've
been told that weights and biases users
love alerts and that some have saved
large cloud gpu bills by being alerted
early to crashed runs while training
large expensive models so relatable try
out weights and biases alerts now at 1db
dot me slash ai coffee break great let's
go back to today's topic of comparing
multi-head self-attention with
convolutions we got mixed signals about
vision transformers during the last
decades in machine learning whom are we
kidding vit was published september 2020
which admittedly feels like a decade ago
because of the insane pace of the field
if you want a quick recap about vision
transformers do check out our playlist
about them here we make a recap on
multi-head self-attention or short msa
and convolutions the convolutional layer
involves a kernel basically a small
matrix containing some numbers that
slides over the input and processes
every region in the same manner it's the
same kernel values that get multiplied
with the different values of the input
so the parameters are shared between
image locations inducing translation
echivarians since if we move the input
across the image and we apply the same
weights everywhere in the image the
output will remain the same but
translate accordingly sharing parameters
so having the same parameters
independently of the image region is
also a big plus if one wants to save
memory but then there's multi-head
self-attention or short msa that laughs
at the whole concept of sharing
parameters across the spatial dimension
and instead dynamically computes a
weight for each token we remember the
sequence spans across the spatial
dimension let's break this down we
remember that 16 by 16 image patches are
represented as vectors or in other words
image tokens to compute a new
representation for this token here
attention scores are computed between
this token and every other token in the
sequence including oneself then the
representations of these image tokens
are aggregated by a weighted sum in
which the weight of each token is given
by the attention score so in this
example here this token contributes a
lot for computing this new
representation this other token only
very little of course we do this for all
tokens so before we had convolutions
that compute a new representation for
each pixel by taking the sum between all
the pixels in a region weighted by the
entries of the kernel and now we have
the self-attention layer the result of
which is a weighted average of all these
image vectors that represent patches
like in convolutions but now the weights
of the sum are first positive and second
dynamically computed through this
renowned formula here where we remember
that the data itself is considered here
in the keys and queries in other words
these attention scores are highly data
dependent and not static like the kernel
values of the convolution don't be
confused we are talking about inference
here or about one iteration during
training of course kernel values updates
during training so they can adapt to the
data and the task at hand when we say
that columns are static we mean that at
one iteration or at inference time they
are fixed and do not depend on the data
sample or spatial region in the data
while attention weights are computed for
each data vector individually another
difference between msa and comms is that
for msas the weighted aggregation is
done over the entire input so unlike
convolutions in cnn that are usually
small windows like three by three and
encompass a small spatial range in the
image self-attention encompasses a much
longer range the whole image and why did
we say that msa laughs at the concept of
saving memory well while self-attention
computes one score between each two
image tokens multi-head self-attention
says ah come on why decide for only one
set of scores if we can have 2 or 6 or
12
in this way the network does not have to
rely on one combination of attention
scores but on many of them that have the
chance to specialize this idea follows
the motto that ensembling is in general
beneficial in machine learning in a
similar manner convolutional networks do
not work with only one kernel per layer
but with more of them where the weights
can be adapted during training to
specialize for specific features great
this was the short recap on msas vs
convs and we basically only explained
the background of this little paragraph
in the paper so assuming we already know
the key components of vision
transformers during the last one and a
half year in which we had time to study
them we still got quite a mixed signals
about what is now exactly the difference
between converse and msas and this is
what i love about this paper it puts all
of this together to get a more coherent
picture about what exactly makes vision
transformers great the introduction of
the paper reminds us of what we have
been saying previously in our videos too
we think that the success of
transformers in general and msa in
particular is due to two main reasons
first the weak inductive bias of msa
while convolutions have this parameter
sharing property throughout the spatial
dimension msa doesn't so each image
region can be handled by its own
specific attention weights even more
these attention weights are data
specific as we discussed earlier so
there are more degrees of freedom when
modelling with msa than with
convolutions and the network has the
chance to discover translation
equivalence on its own or even cooler
properties if they are useful for
minimizing the loss and because there is
less guidance from the start for the
network vision transformers are
notorious to overfit on small data sets
it sure remains to be seen in this video
whether this is true but we know that
techniques involving heavy data
augmentation are needed for small data
regimes as we have seen with
making vit work on smaller data sets the
second reason is the extremely large
context window of vanilla msa that
computes a tension scores for each token
based on every single other token
attending to a wider context should lead
to better performance right
right
let's follow this paper related work to
see why this is not really the case
modeling long-range dependencies does
not necessarily result in higher
performance there are examples in the
literature showing how a limited context
window of msa is beneficial on small and
large data sets alike like we have seen
with the swin transformer in one of our
previous videos and then there's these
facts we should make sense of adding msa
to cnns helps especially when msa is
added closer to the last layer and then
we cite vits are robust against data
corruption and image occlusions and
especially against adversarial attacks
where the attack consists of introducing
high frequency noise so what is it with
msa and the insensitivity to high
frequencies now okay hold your questions
because this paper is going to address
them by hypothesizing that msa is a
trainable spatial smoothing of feature
maps and this makes sense when looking
at the formula of self-attention we take
the image vectors or features across the
spatial dimension and average them with
importance weights that are all positive
so the authors go ahead and ask three
questions what properties of msa do we
need to better optimize neural networks
do msas act like convs if not how are
they different
and third how can we harmonize msas with
convs following the last question they
propose an architecture combining msa
and convolutions based on the lessons
learned from answering the first two
questions before going further into this
miss kofibin wants me to make a small
comment on how the authors arrived at
their conclusions the authors answered
these questions by conducting their
experiments on
scifire only i mean it is great that
they compare different models like the
resnet which is a confident and
transformers like vit pit and swin it's
problematic again that they use the tiny
versions of these models but we have two
questions what about data sets other
than sci-fi and how do the lessons of
this paper generalize for tasks other
than image classification
so for something like object detection
or image segmentation keep this in mind
throughout this video let's follow the
paper and answer the first question what
properties of msas do we need to improve
optimization well the first lesson here
is unsurprising it seems like msa is
acting like a more generalized spatial
pooling generalized because it is
trainable and data dependent and this is
a good inductive bias for image data
only think about the data specificity
it's a nice thing to have something we
do not find in a data independent
aggregation layer like we have in the
mlp mixer nothing against the mlp mixer
it's really useful if we dislike the
compute and memory footprint of msa and
are ready for a compromise in accuracy
the surprising bit is that due to the
weaker inductive bias of msa the
training of msa-based neural networks is
more difficult they do not even overfit
on small training data sets we see here
how two curves for training and test of
vit on scifire 100 are very close to
each other and are not exhibiting the
gap specific to overfitting not even in
the small data regimes of course this is
also helped by the strong deity-like
data augmentation the authors apply to
vit also interesting but not surprising
after we have learned about swin
transformers and convex is that not the
huge context window of msa is the recipe
to success but a reduction of the
degrees of freedom by limiting msa to
very small windows we see in this
picture how the lowest test error is
achieved with a three by three window
size for msa but miss coffee bean must
comment again because the authors
conduct experiments on cipher 100 where
we would assume that long dependencies
are not key for good performance we
expect this lesson to vary on more
complex data sets and on tasks other
than image recognition
image recognition is too holistic for
this i guess describing the whole image
with one label is not very challenging
and we would like to see results on
other tasks like action recognition
where it is important to model how two
different corners of the image interact
with one another but a cool thing to
find out is that msa comes with both
advantages and disadvantages on the
bright side msas flatten the lost
landscapes a flat landscape means better
performance and generalization because
you know
landing here or landing there on the
lost landscape does not change much in a
less flat landscape it means a lot if i
land here or over there but how do the
authors know that the landscape is
flatter for msa well they look at the
eigenvalues of the hessian matrix
short reminder the hessian matrix of the
loss function is a square matrix
containing the second partial
derivatives of the loss function in
english please we take two directions in
our high dimensional space that the loss
function lives in and ask how does the
change in one direction change with
respect to the other direction and the
eigenvectors of this hessian matrix are
the principal directions of curvature
the eigenvalues speak about the
magnitude of that curvature a big
hessian eigenvalue speaks for high
curvature so for a very curvy and
supposedly bumpy lost landscape and
guess what msa suppresses large hessian
eigenvalues so this makes the lost
landscape flatter for vit while the lost
landscape of the resnet has high hessian
eigenvalues does a higher curvature this
is a win for msa on the not so bright
side for msa the authors read another
thing from the hessian of the loss
function especially in the regimes of
little data a lot of hessian eigenvalues
turn out to be negative so the lost
landscape is non-convex for msa and if
you hear non-convex prepare for local
minima that the optimizer might not
escape from but the good news is that
more data also makes for less negative
hessian eigenvalues so more convex
losses given that in small data regimes
the lost landscape is non-convex it is
again interesting to see that vit does
not overfit when training on small data
sets
so now what is the difference between
msa and convolutions first something we
have discussed already convolutions are
data agnostic and msas are data specific
secondly convolutions are channel
specific where kernels are learned for
each channel and msa does not care on
which channel they are applied in fact
the patches that first consist of three
channels for red green and blue are all
smashed together into one vector so if
we cite cons are data agnostic and
channel specific in contrast msas are
data specific and channel agnostic then
the conclusion of this paper is that
they should be complementary so we need
them both nice
more interesting for miss coffee bean is
that msas are low pass filters but cons
are high pass filters what does this
mean now a low pass filter lets the low
frequencies pass so things like shape
and white patterns in the image get
through while sharp details do not
think about the low frequencies as the
information that remains after blurring
the image convolutions on the other hand
are high pass filters meaning that they
let high frequencies pass like very fine
edges in texture therefore it is no
wonder that we sight the results does
suggest that msas are shape biased where
convs are texture biased which also
confirms findings of previous work the
authors see this high pass and low pass
characteristics by doing a fourier
decomposition of vit and resnet features
respectively and comparing the resulting
frequencies also we are not surprised
that cnns which are high pass filters
not filtering out high frequencies are
vulnerable to high frequency noise and
adversarial attacks that introduce high
frequencies into the image so high that
the human eye cannot even see and the
last difference we will discuss here
between msas and convs is that msas
average feature maps and reduce the
variance of the feature maps in an
ensembling like effect the authors
support this by showing how msas rather
reduce the variance and constant mlps
increase the variance in their
experiments so it is no wonder that
based on this the authors move on to the
third question of the paper of how can
we harmonize msas with convs and propose
alternet which in a nutshell is a resnet
with msa blocks after each stage
especially at late stages to reduce
feature map variants we will let you
decide what you think about this
architecture after you find out about
all its details
honestly due to the limited data sets
tasks and baselines explored in this
paper we are not very impressed by
alternet but we have seen with convnext
that an enhanced resnet can achieve good
performance so we do believe the
author's message here that marrying
convicts with msa seems like a good idea
if you want to know all the details that
we missed or got wrong
read the paper we have mixed feelings
about its style on the one hand it has a
good choice of words and flow of ideas
but it is also extremely dense and
sometimes the required details are in
unexpected places thanks for watching
and sorry you had to wait for so long
for this next video phd life is
demanding and miss coffee bean isn't
animating herself
[Music]